Speaker 1: Let's look at a very interesting
segment from Fox News yesterday.
This is a segment in which Jesse Waters, I
believe, is the host of this program, this right
winger who's very popular on social media, one
of the top view getters on Facebook, Dan Bongino,
is a guest or panelist. And the topic is crime in
the United States. This is a favorite topic right
now of the right to lie about and to deceive
people about on right wing media and Fox. I
guess she's like a contributor. She's a guest
on this program. Fox contributor Jessica Tarlov
absolutely crushes Waters and Bongino. Now,
I don't Jessica Tarlov may be a centrist. I
don't know that much about her. I'm not calling
her a hero. I'm not saying anything other than
in this particular segment. She's really, really
good at crushing the dishonest, delusional lives
of two of these guys on Fox News. So let's
look at the segment again. The framing
here is the crime surge, which Republicans are
attributing to Joe Biden, but they're using 20,
20 data to attribute it to Joe Biden. Now,
you might be saying, hold on, David Trump was
president in twenty twenty. How does that have to
do with Joe Biden? And that is exactly the right
question. So let's take a look at the segment.
Speaker 3: And the spike in murders, again,
was only in areas dominated by liberal
politicians. So this is obviously not
true. It's obviously has something to do with the
Speaker 1: politics not covered. So the framing
there is we're going to talk about the fact that
the crime is up in cities rather than the fact
that the crime was up while Trump was president.
But, of course, we've talked before. Cities tend
to be run by Democrats, quote, dangerous cities
are run by Democrats and safe cities are run by
Democrats because in general, Democrats prefer
cities and Republicans prefer non cities. OK,
let's see how Jessica Tarlov deals with this.
Speaker 4: I'm not sure that it has something
to do necessarily with the politics. There
are a few things that are important here. One,
Jesse will do another segment on that. But
all those countries you read, they don't have
a rampant gun problem like the United States of
America does. Check how many weapons people can
Speaker 3: kill you with a knife. But they're not
Speaker 4: there. They're not in Colombia. I lived
in the time where people got knifed all the time
and it's still nothing close to our murder rates.
Speaker 1: OK, this is a this is they love
this talking point, but it's very dumb.
Knives create less death than guns in equivalent
situations. Part of it is to kill someone with a
knife. There's something much more. Sometimes
viscerally repelling, I mean, the action,
right, of stabbing someone to death, you've got
to be people not throwing knives from across the
room. You've got to be right on someone. And the
fact that with a gun you can create more distance
and still inflict damage to someone just
makes it less likely that a mass stabbing
would even be attempted in the same way that
the mass shooting would be. But we have data
about mass stabbings and most people survive one
of the most deadly mass stabbings. We covered it
at the time. It was in twenty nineteen in Japan.
Two people were tragically killed. Two kids,
17 were injured and survived, someone with
a semiautomatic weapon in that situation,
with the amount of time that this incident
lasted, would almost certainly kill many,
many more people. So good that good for
Jessica Tarlov for pointing that out.
Jesse Watters is going to say people can be killed
by knives. Fine. It may not convinced that many
people on Fox News, but Jessica Tarlov is getting
it right now. Let's get to the 20 thing, which is
just unbelievably dumb that they're doing.
Speaker 4: The data that we're talking about
is 20, 20. Those were the Trump years. So all of
this blaming on President Biden, that's happening
now. Actually, under President Biden's watch, the
murder rate has even gone down. Another important
component of the FBI data that the short term
increases was in all regions, not just in those
liberal cities, all regions. That means in places
where conservatives are, that means that this can
all be because of bail reform to fund the police,
yadda, yadda, yadda. And also the murder rate and
the crime rate overall is lower than it was in
the 1990s. So conservatives are running around
screaming, we've never seen anything like
this. You have seen something like this.
Speaker 1: So these are all very good points.
And they all should be dealt with individually.
If the problem is that the the danger and
crime are happening in liberal cities,
we need to adjust for the fact that liberals tend
to live in cities and run cities and conservatives
tend to overall live in more rural and suburban
areas. And in terms of per capita crime rates,
we actually see that per capita, some of those
rural areas are really, really dangerous. The
problem is it's hard to compare a city to
a tiny town. You have you have really have
to look at an area where you have enough of a
population to actually evaluate this. And then,
of course, number two, long term, the crime rate
has been going down. We did see a bump in 2020,
but Trump was president and much of it was
despair related to the mishandled pandemic. They
were blaming Biden back then saying, well, it's
the culture of people who would vote for Biden,
combined with people saying we should defund the
police, even though it hadn't actually been done.
It had just been proposed by some. But
I thought the buck stops with Trump
or whoever was president. So this is a really
great example of the narratives that they push,
not having anything to do with the facts. And
a sensible person in this case, Jessica Tarlov,
just saying, hold on, let's put some facts in
the way of the propaganda. How many Fox viewers
were convinced by this? I have no idea. Maybe
not many, but this is exactly the way that if
you're going to participate and Jessica Tarlov
is a contributor to FOX. So clearly she is
if you're going to participate in these
setup debates that are set up against you,
this is exactly the way to do it. We'll have
more on this on The David Pakman Show Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show. You
can also find me on Instagram at David Pakman.